bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour la
FAQ 700000 abonnés et même si on a
dépassé la période réglementaire des 31
jours je vous souhaite à tous une
excellente année 2023 alors cette année
2022 qui vient de s'achever a été
extrêmement riche j'ai l'impression de
dire ça à chaque début d'année mais
c'est la vérité évidemment le plus gros
projet qui a marqué cette année 2022
c'est mon projet de bande dessinée
filorama un projet qui a rencontré un
grand succès puisque vous avez été plus
de 4000 contributeurs à avoir
précommandé la bande dessinée d'ailleurs
je crois même que c'est l'un des plus
gros projets Ulule qui a eu lieu sur la
plateforme l'année passée et donc je
saisis l'occasion pour vous dire qu'on
avance bien qu'on avance même très bien
sur la bande dessinée on en est déjà à
la cinquième histoire donc on est dans
les temps et la bande dessinée vous sera
livrée comme prévu à la fin de cette
année pour que vous puissiez l'offrir
pour les fêtes de Noël je crois que
certaines personnes ont cru livrer la
bande dessinée fin 2022 bien entendu ce
n'était pas possible puisqu'on a lancé
le projet en octobre donc deux mois pour
réaliser imprimer envoyer la BD c'était
un petit peu compliqué et de toute façon
si vous êtes contributeur Ulule vous
recevez une notification à chaque fois
que je publie une news sur la page Lule
pour que vous tenir informé de
l'avancement du projet autre fait
marquant de cette année 2022 c'est la
progression assez spectaculaire de ma
page patréon donc je vous rappelle que
sur ma page pas créole je publie du
contenu totalement inédit du contenu qui
n'apparaît sur aucun de mes réseaux
sociaux ni sur Youtube ni sur Instagram
et parmi les différents formats que je
propose sur ma page patréon il y a les
capsules concept on en est déjà à la 17e
il y a également les épisodes retours
que je publie généralement quelques
jours après la sortie de mon dernier
audio philo et parmi tous les autres
avantages il y a également la sortie des
épisodes en avant-première c'est à dire
que
sort mes épisodes sur Youtube le
vendredi sur ma page patronne vous y
avez accès dès le mardi il y a également
les cours que je donne une fois par mois
les replay de ses cours ainsi que les
apérophilos que j'organise une fois tous
les deux mois donc si vous êtes
intéressé par ce contenu et bien le
mieux c'est de vous rendre directement
sur ma page patréon le lien est dans la
description et l'avantage c'est que bien
si vous souscrivez à cette page pas très
haute non seulement vous aurez bien
entendu accès à tout le contenu que je
vais publier à partir de votre
inscription mais également à tout le
contenu qui a été publié depuis la
création de la page ce qui veut dire que
tous les épisodes retours toutes les
capsules concept toutes les disserts
minutes vous aurez accès si vous vous
inscrivez maintenant et pour conclure ce
bilan de l'année sur un plan un peu plus
prosaïque et bien sachez que la chaîne a
enregistré 200 000 abonnés
supplémentaires en 2022 donc on est sur
une progression qui se maintient on est
sur une progression quasiment linéaire
et tout ce qu'on vous le souhaitez c'est
que ça continue comme ça encore
longtemps donc a priori tout va pour le
mieux et effectivement tout va pour le
mieux mais il y a quand même quelque
chose dont j'aimerais vous parler et qui
concerne les modifications du règlement
de YouTube en gros pour vous expliquer
rapidement comment ça se passe du côté
créateur lorsque vous publiez une vidéo
sur Youtube vous devez confirmer que
cette vidéo n'en fera pas le règlement
de YouTube et s'il s'avère que la vidéo
que vous publiez sur Youtube ne respecte
pas le règlement bien vous risquez
plusieurs choses au mieux la
démonétisation c'est à dire que votre
vidéo nous vous rapportera pas de revenu
au pire vous pouvez recevoir un
avertissement et au bout de trois
avertissements ce qu'on appelle des
strikes votre chaîne et purement et
simplement supprimer et attention quand
je dis que votre chaîne est supprimée ça
ne veut pas dire seulement que vous ne
pouvez pas publier de nouvelles vidéos
ça veut dire que toutes vos anciennes
vidéos disp donc autant dire que vous
mettez la clé sous la porte et pourquoi
je vous parle de tout ça et bien parce
que récemment YouTube a remis à jour son
règlement et maintenant ça va beaucoup
plus loin c'est à dire que YouTube va
jusqu'à interdire l'usage de gros mots
et c'est ce qui fait que de plus en plus
sur Youtube vous allez voir des vidéos
dans lesquelles il y a des bips pour
censurer les mots interdits ou dans
lesquels il y a des mots volontairement
mal prononcé ça c'est une technique
utilisée certains créateurs pour essayer
de de contourner l'interdiction pour
essayer de mettre en défaut le détecteur
de mots interdit sur Youtube et moi
concrètement je ne suis pas le plus
directement visé par ce nouveau
règlement de YouTube parce que mes
épisodes contiennent assez peu de mots
grossier mais il faut savoir que ça ne
concerne pas seulement les gros mots ça
concerne aussi tout ce qui va être
considéré comme étant des propos
sensibles ou des propos polémiques alors
sensible polémique on pourrait répondre
que c'est très subjectif oui mais sauf
que YouTube a mis au point un algorithme
qui permet de détecter un certain nombre
de mots tout ce qui va être lié par
exemple au racisme tout ce qui va être
lié au sexisme tout ce qui va être lié à
la violence à l'appel à la haine ou à
des événements sensibles et bien tout ça
sera dorénavant censuré et sachez que ça
va très loin parce qu'il y a même des
chaînes YouTube d'histoire qui ont vu
certaines de leurs vidéos démonétisées
parce qu'elle parlait de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale ou parce qu'elle parlait
de l'esclavage ou de la colonisation et
que tous ces sujets sont dorénavant
considérés comme problématique sur
Youtube donc si je vous parle de tout ça
c'est tout simplement pour vous dire que
on ne sait jamais de quoi demain est
fait il est tout à fait possible que
YouTube continue à serrer la vis et à
restreindre les sujets autorisés par les
créateurs de contenu et qu'il est tout à
fait possible qu'on se retrouve demain
avec des vidéos de philosophie censurées
parce qu'elles auront évoqué des
thématiques sujet des questions qui
seront considérées comme étant trop
sensibles sur Youtube alors on va pas se
mentir si YouTube fait tout ça ce n'est
pas pour préserver les enfants de la
plateforme c'est bien entendu parce que
ça correspond à une demande des
annonceurs publicitaires des annonceurs
publicitaires qui ne veulent pas voir le
nom de leur marque mêlés à des propos
choquants et clairement on voit que
YouTube s'orient de plus en plus dans du
contenu de pure divertissement en plus
de la musique donc autant vous dire que
les contenus culturels et les contenus
philosophiques ça pèse pas lourd dans la
balance et c'est pas ça qu'il est fera
changer d'avis alors moi il se trouve
que j'ai un principe qui est de ne pas
me plaindre d'une situation que je
connais et que j'accepte donc je refuse
de me plaindre de ce nouveau règlement
du tube tout simplement parce que vivre
de YouTube ne fait pas partie des droits
fondamentaux de l'être humain YouTube
est une plateforme privée qui a un
règlement on peut l'accepter on peut le
refuser et si je ne suis pas content je
quitte la plateforme mais sachez que
dans un avenir plus ou moins lointain il
est possible que ma chaîne fasse
également les frais de cette politique
de censure de YouTube parce que dans
certains de mes épisodes je parle de la
mort je parle du suicide je parle du
totalitarisme et que tous ces sujets
peuvent être considérés comme choquants
peuvent être considérés comme sensibles
on en revient à la question de la
subjectivité de la sensibilité qui fait
que si ces propos ne sont pas choquants
pour les uns ils le sont pour les autres
et comme on est dans une société
médiatique de plus en plus aseptisée de
plus en plus lisse il me semble
inévitable qu'un jour ou l'autre cette
question se posera également pour ma
chaîne et c'est ce qui fait par exemple
que j'ai prévu de faire un épisode sur
shopenhauer et les femmes et bien cet
épisode je ne le publierai pas sur
Youtube parce que shopenhauer vous le
connaissez vous savez que c'était
quelqu'un d'extrêmement misogyne et donc
lorsque je vais parler dans mon épisode
de ce que disait Schopenhauer à propos
des femmes il va y avoir des propos
choquants et même si ce ne sont pas mes
propos personnels même si je ne fais que
rapporter les propos de Schopenhauer peu
importe pour Youtube c'est déjà
considéré comme problématique je
pourrais même les critiquer je pourrais
même les dénoncer que du point de vue du
règlement de YouTube ça ne changerait
strictement rien parce que tout ce qui
est intéressant Youtube c'est de savoir
quels mots sont prononcés YouTube se
moque de savoir quelle est l'approche
que vous allez avoir de ces sujets
YouTube se contente de détecter des mots
interdits donc cet épisode sur
shopenhauer et les femmes sera
disponible uniquement sur ma page
patréon parce que j'ai pas envie de
commencer à jouer à la roulette russe
avec l'algorithme de YouTube et aussi
parce que je n'ai pas du tout envie de
me censurer ou de moto censurer pour
correspondre pour satisfaire le bon
vouloir des annonceurs publicitaires
j'ai créé ma chaîne youtube il y a
bientôt cinq ans c'est une activité dans
laquelle je m'épanouis dans lequel je
m'accomplis et me sent utile et donc je
n'ai pas du tout envie de rentrer dans
une sorte de guéguerre ou de posture
d'indignation vis-à-vis de YouTube
j'estime que c'est à nous créateur de
contenu de prendre nos responsabilités
et si on se rend dépendant d'une
plateforme qui ne nous appartient pas il
ne faut pas s'étonner il ne faut pas se
plaindre le jour où cette plateforme
décide de changer ses règles et pour ma
part j'estime que la philosophie est une
discipline incompatible avec la censure
puisqu'en philosophie on parle de tout
on traite de tous les sujets on ne
s'interdit rien on ne proie rien donc
vous le savez maintenant je ne
m'adonnerai pas à l'autocensure je ne
m'adonnerai pas aux travestissement de
mes propos et si demain tout ça devait
s'arrêter et bien ça s'arrêtera et ça
continuera sous d'autres cieux voilà
j'ai terminé ce très long préambule que
je tenais à vous faire parce que c'est
important aussi de vous tenir informé
des coulisses de notre travail de
créateur et que vous sachiez aussi
comment on vit et comment on réagit à
tout ce qu'il se passe derrière l'écran
voilà je vais maintenant passer aux
réponses à vos questions je vous
rappelle que pour m'envoyer vos
questions pour les FAQ le plus simple
c'est de me rejoindre sur Instagram
c'est le réseau social sur lequel je
suis le plus actif et comme d'habitude
désolé à tous ceux dont je n'aurais pas
retenu la question vous aurez d'autres
occasions c'est parti première question
est-ce que tu aurais un jour pensé à
atteindre le chiffre de 700 000 abonnés
sinon j'adore tes vidéos alors au
lancement de ma chaîne absolument pas au
lancement de ma chaîne je crois même me
souvenir que j'avais dit que j'espérais
avoir 1000 abonnés la première année
5000 la deuxième et 20 000 la troisième
je crois je peux me tromper que j'ai
atteint les 100.000 abonnés au bout d'un
peu plus de deux ans d'activités sur
cette chaîne Youtube et à partir du
moment où j'ai atteint les 100 000
abonnés j'ai commencé à me dire qu'il
tout à fait possible que la progression
continue mais la raison profonde pour
laquelle je reste surpris que cette
chaîne compte autant d'abonnés c'est
tout simplement à cause du format je ne
pensais pas qu'un format audio qu'un
format
minimaliste dans le montage et dans
l'esthétique puisse être aussi populaire
en fait ça correspond à un préjugé que
j'avais dans la tête qui était que la
masse pour employer cette expression qui
ne veut pas dire grand chose que la
masse était uniquement intéressée par du
contenu purement divertissant ou par du
contenu
ultra dynamique donc ça a été une belle
leçon d'humilité ça a été aussi une
belle leçon de compréhension
compréhension de ce qui plaît de ce qui
intéresse les gens et même si le nombre
d'abonnés en soi n'a pas vraiment de
valeur c'est surtout symbolique mais
c'est quand même révélateur c'est quand
même symptomatique de quelque chose
de l'époque que nous traversons
actuellement est de ce besoin de sens
qui marque généralement les périodes de
crise et donc je ne vais pas me cacher
derrière mon petit doigt je suis très
content de savoir que mon nombre
d'abonnés augmente parce que ça signifie
quelque chose ça signifie que les gens
sont attirés par le monde de la pensée
par le monde de la réflexion que les
gens ne sont pas attirés seulement par
les contenus abrutissants par les
contenus faciles à consommer facile à
digérer et je sais que parmi mes abonnés
de longue date il y en a certains qui
auraient voulu que ma chaîne reste
confidentielle selon l'idée que plus
quelque chose est populaire plus quelque
chose gagne en visibilité et plus ça
devient finalement pour faire de
l'argent plus ça devient quelque chose
qui fait partie du système et donc plus
on aurait abandonné ces anciens projets
ses anciennes convictions pour ma part
et même si je sais qu'on est le plus
mauvais juge de soi-même mais pour ma
part j'ai plutôt l'impression que ce
gain de visibilité m'a au contraire
permis de faire ce que je voulais faire
c'est à dire à pouvoir passer
l'intégralité de mon temps à créer du
contenu à créer du contenu qui soit à
chaque fois un peu meilleur maintenant
comme je vous l'ai dit on est le plus
mauvais juge de soi-même donc si vous
vous avez le sentiment que la qualité de
la chaîne a baissé au fur et à mesure du
temps et bien n'hésitez pas à me le dire
vous pouvez vous exprimer dans les
commentaires et inversement d'ailleurs
si vous pensez au contraire que la
qualité a augmenté et bien n'hésitez pas
à me le dire les commentaires sont là
pour ça question suivante
quand tu produire du contenu toute ta
vie ou NES qu'une étape bien c'est
difficile de répondre à cette question
parce que comme je disais tout à l'heure
on ne sait jamais de quoi demain sera
fait et puis aussi parce que
j'appartiens à une génération pour
laquelle l'instabilité la précarité
l'évolution permanente font un peu
partie des choses qu'on a intégré donc
ça veut dire que je vis très bien avec
l'idée que je ne sais pas encore ce que
je ferai dans un an dans 5 ans dans 10
ans même si évidemment je souhaiterais
que mon travail sur YouTube sur les
podcasts continuez encore pendant
plusieurs années mais ce n'est pas parce
que je le souhaite que ce sera
effectivement le cas et puis aussi
peut-être que un jour je l'aurai tout
simplement marre et que j'aurais envie
de faire autre chose quand je dis faire
autre chose ça peut être produire du
contenu sous un autre format par exemple
le format écrit écrire des livres ça
fait partie des possibilités que je peux
envisager peut-être que passer mes 40
ans 45 ans j'aurais envie de me
consacrer à l'écriture ou peut-être que
j'aurai envie de faire quelque chose de
totalement différent peut-être que
j'aurais envie de reprendre un travail
manuel ou peut-être que je deviendrai
coach sportif ou prof de salsa le fait
que ce n'est pas une chose qui me
préoccupe parce que je pense que l'être
humain se caractérise par sa capacité
d'adaptation et que si un jour pour une
raison pour une autre je mettais un
terme à mon activité sur Youtube je sais
que je trouverai autre chose dans quoi
m'épanouir question suivante
aimeriez-vous écrire un livre par
exemple un essai sur la philo alors j'ai
commencé plus ou moins à répondre à
cette question tout à l'heure parce que
la réponse c'est oui oui j'ai de plus en
plus envie d'écrire un livre de
philosophie j'ai même déjà à l'esprit la
thématique que j'aimerais traiter dans
ce livre mais simplement c'est le
privilège de l'âge je sais que lorsqu'on
s'avance un peu trop et lorsqu'on
annonce
trop vite le fait qu'on va écrire un
livre bien généralement on produit
surtout de la déception chez nos
auditeurs ou et futurs lecteurs parce
que ça prend du temps ça prend du temps
et donc entre le moment où on l'annonce
c'est le moment où le livre est
réellement écrit il peut se passer
plusieurs années et je n'ai pas du tout
envie de jouer à ce petit jeu là avec
vous je n’ai pas envie de vous annoncer
quelque chose qui ne verra le jour que
dans trois cinq voire 10 ans et
d'ailleurs quand j'ai lancé le projet
philorama donc en octobre 2022 la
réalité c'est que je travaillais sur ce
projet depuis le mois de mai donc ça
faisait déjà 5 mois que j'étais sur ce
projet ça faisait 5 mois et je savais
qu'il fallait encore un peu plus d'un an
pour faire aboutir ce projet de bande
dessinée et donc je ne serai absolument
pas amusé à vous annoncer ce projet à
vous l'annoncer officiellement si je ne
l'avais pas encore entamé mais si je
peux déjà donner quelques ind ce livre
de philosophie que j'aimerais écrire
très très sous un mode philosophique de
la trajectoire de l'humanité de la
préhistoire à nos jours ça peut vous
faire penser à un autre livre un
best-seller de ces dernières années ce
sera très différent question suivante
ressent-tu au moment de réaliser tes
vidéos une responsabilité face au public
et bien oui je ressens une
responsabilité face au public mais ce
qui me facilite les choses c'est que
j'éprouve d'abord une responsabilité
face à moi-même c'est à dire que je suis
un peu un maniaque de l'exigence
j'oserais pas dire que je suis
perfectionniste mais un peu quand même
en fait si je suis clairement
perfectionniste mais on va dire que avec
l'âge j'ai appris à gérer ça et à un
petit peu desserré un petit peu lâcher
du lest sur mon perfectionnisme j'ai
appris à gérer ça à être un peu plus
tolérant voir un peu plus coulant avec
moi-même quand c'est nécessaire parce
que je sais que la perfection est
parfois l'ennemi de l'action et que même
si je sortais un épisode en ayant la
conviction profonde et intime que tout
est parfait qu'il n'y a aucun défaut
rien à ajouter rien à enlever je sais
que ce ne serait mon sentiment qu'au
moment de le publier et qu'il suffirait
d'attendre un an un mois voire une
semaine pour que je me dise qu'en fait
tout était à reprendre ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que je ne confonds pas
le sentiment de responsabilité avec
l'hyper exigence qui empêche d'avancer
parce que je fais partie de ceux qui
sont convaincus que c'est par la
pratique qu'on s'améliore et que donc si
on veut faire quelque chose de parfait
sans s'être trompé sans avoir fait
d'erreur sans avoir commis
d'imperfection et bien on ne peut pas
s'améliorer donc vouloir être d'emblée
dans la perfection sans être passé par
toutes les étapes de l'apprentissage et
de l'amélioration ça me semble être une
contradiction dans les termes donc oui
j'éprouve une responsabilité face au
public responsabilité d'ailleurs qui
porte non pas sur la manière dont vont
être interprétés mais épisodes mais
plutôt sur la fidélité de ce que je dis
au contenu réel de la pensée des auteurs
autrement dit pour le dire simplement
qu'une vidéo sur la mort
puisse toucher puisse affecter
négativement mon spectateur ça c'est
quelque chose dont je n'éprouve pas la
responsabilité je n'éprouve pas la
responsabilité de ça parce que j'estime
qu'il n'y a pas de manière consensuelle
de traiter de sujets qui ne sont pas
consensuels d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait
que en introduction de mon épisode sur
la mort chez piqûres j'ai commencé par
une blague j'ai commencé par une blague
pour mettre les pieds dans le plat pour
briser la glace et pour dire que bah oui
on va parler de la mort la mort est un
sujet triste dramatique voire tragique
mais ça c'est un point de vue culturel
sur lequel je n'ai pas de prise sur
lequel je ne peux rien et j'estime que
je n'ai pas à m'interdire de parler de
sujets de ce type sous prétexte que ça
risque d'être attrister certains de mes
auditeurs je dirais que si je décide de
traiter d'un sujet choquant je ne vais
pas me poser la question de savoir si je
vais choquer je préfère partir du
principe que oui et me dire que après
tout on n'est pas obligé de m'écouter
question suivante
quel est ton profil MBTI alors si j'ai
bonne mémoire je crois que lorsque j'ai
passé ce test MBTI le résultat c'était
l'architecte je crois en tout cas qu'une
fois j'avais eu comme résultat
l'architecte et que je l'avais repassé
quelques temps plus tard et que cette
fois-ci j'étais plutôt le directeur mais
c'est vrai que sur les le test en
général les tests de personnalité de
profils psychologiques il m'arrive de ne
pas répondre exactement à la même chose
et d'ailleurs ça m'avait inspiré toute
une réflexion sur ce que l'on fait quand
on répond à un test de personnalité
autrement dit ce que l'on fait lorsqu'on
parle de soi parce que remplir un test
de personnalité c'est parler de soi
est-ce que c'est parlé de soi ou est-ce
que c'est parler de l'image qu'on a de
soi et je me souviens avoir discuté il y
a quelques temps avec un ami qui me
disait que on avait tous une tendance
lorsqu'on répond à un questionnaire de
personnalité à répondre non pas ce que
l'on est mais ce que l'on voudrait être
ou en tout cas la manière dont on se
voit la manière dont on se perçoit
l'image qu'on veut renvoyer aux autres
aux autres ou à soi-même d'ailleurs et
c'est là que je me suis dit que les
tests de personnalité étaient
intéressants non pas parce qu'il révèle
notre personnalité mais parce qu'il
révèle ce que nous voulons dégager comme
personnalité est-ce que j'ai réellement
la personnalité de l'architecte c'est
possible j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire
que si j'avais dû faire un autre métier
exercer dans un autre domaine que la
philosophie ça aurait été l'architecture
directeur pourquoi pas si par directeur
on entend diriger et pas forcément
d'ailleurs dirigé une équipe pas
forcément dirigée du personnel je suis
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de mal à
déléguer je suis quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de mal à diriger les autres je
préfère me diriger moi-même voilà je ne
serais pas forcément vu dans cet
exercice et c'est ce qui fait que
j'apprécie énormément de pouvoir
travailler tout seul question suivante
comment tu fais pour tenir un si long
discours en philosophie je dirais que je
suis naturellement bavard et que plus je
suis passionné par un sujet et plus j'ai
envie d'en parler
as-tu fait d'autres sujets comme la
politique la littérature auquel tu
t'intéresses je traite de philosophie
mais aussi de littérature
d'art de culture en général dans
certains de mes épisodes par exemple
dans mon épisode sur Orwell je parle de
la novlang
ce concept d'Orwell il n'apparaît pas
dans un essai de philosophie il apparaît
dans un roman un roman qu'on peut
envisager sous un angle philosophique
lorsque je parle du mythe de Prométhée
lorsque je parle d'Adam et Eve lorsque
je parle de la Grèce ou de l'Egypte je
parle de mythologie je parle de religion
mais je le fais sous un angle
philosophique et à fortiori dans mes
portraits philo quand je parle de Végéta
quand je parle de Rocky ou du roi Arthur
je parle de personnages de fiction donc
on va dire que je peux parler
potentiellement de tout à condition que
ce soit sous un angle philosophique et
d'ailleurs je pense que je serai amené
d'ici les mois ou les années qui
viennent à parler de plus en plus de
romancier et de poètes c'est à dire à
analyser philosophiquement des œuvres
littéraires questions suivantes
pourquoi la philosophie
parce que le besoin de sens des
recommandations de films philo bien un
peu dans la continuité de ce que je
disais précédemment beaucoup de films
peuvent être envisagés sous un angle
philosophique j'ai déjà cité dans de
précédentes FAQ le film The Truman Show
j'ai également parlé de Captain
fantastic matrix bien sûr qui fait
partie des films les plus cités dès
qu'on parle de philosophie au cinéma moi
il se trouve que j'ai un réalisateur et
notamment un film de ce réalisateur que
je trouve d'un contenu philosophique
surpuissant qui est 2001 l'Odyssée de
l'espace parce que c'est un film qui
pose en creux même pas en creux
d'ailleurs de manière assez explicite en
fait la question de l'origine de
l'humanité et de la définition de la
signification du fait d'être humain et
d'ailleurs toute la coloration mysticot
ésotérique de film n'est pas pour me
déplaire maintenant et c'est pas très
original de le dire mais peu importe
c'est ce que je pense je fais partie de
ceux qui considèrent qu'on peut trouver
de la philosophie un peu partout et donc
le dernier film que je suis allé voir au
cinéma qui était Avatar 2 moi je l'ai
pas vu comme un film philosophique en
revanche je l'ai vu comme un film qui
nous donnait parfois l'occasion de nous
interroger sur le sens philosophique de
certaines choses et je ne parle pas du
tout de tout l'aspect écologiste
environnementaliste du film mais je
pense plutôt à une scène qui se trouve à
la toute fin du film alors je préviens
tout de suite si vous ne voulez pas être
spoilé avancer d'environ 30 secondes
c'est une scène située à la fin du film
ou l'enfant humain qui vit parmi les
habitants de Pandora
sauve la vie du méchant
et il semblerait que s'il lui sauve la
vie c'est parce qu'il sait que ce
méchant et son père je me suis dit que
ça devait avoir un sens non pas
seulement pour le scénario et pour la
suite mais aussi un sens philosophique
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait un message
dans ce geste et ce message n'était pas
le message du pardon parce que le
méchant n'éprouve absolument aucune
culpabilité il n'est pas du tout dans
une démarche de repentir c'est l'enfant
lui-même qui de sa propre initiative
décide de lui sauver la vie comme s'il y
avait quelque chose de plus fort comme
s'il y avait quelque chose de
viscéralement humain dans cet acte et si
on admet avec shopenhauer que le fait
d'aimer ses parents ou le fait que les
parents aiment leurs enfants c'est en
fait une version différée de l'amour de
soi c'est à dire de l'instinct
d'autoconservation et bien ce sauvetage
du méchant à la fin du film a peut-être
une portée beaucoup plus Phil aussi
qu'on ne le pense question suivante
pratiques-tu des sports de combat alors
j'ai pratiqué des sports de combat j'ai
pratiqué la boxe anglaise j'ai pratiqué
un petit peu la box pieds points mais ça
fait tellement d'années maintenant que
je n'ose plus vraiment me revendiquer de
ses sports et je pense que si je m'y
remettais il faudrait que je reprenne
quasiment tout à la base
tu es plutôt crochet du gauche ou
uppercut au froid bien à l'époque je
faisais de la boxe anglaise j'étais
plutôt hyper cuite au menton d'où vient
cette idée du sportif idiot et de la
dichotomie entre corps et esprit ça je
pense que ça remonte à une très
lointaine distinction la distinction
corps esprit qu'on trouve déjà chez les
philosophes de l'Antiquité notamment
chez Platon en fait c'est l'idée que
l'esprit et la région supérieure de
l'être humain tandis que le corps c'est
la partie basse c'est la partie qui nous
rattache à notre animalité à notre
instinct donc ces Platon le bas ventre
la partie animale de l'être humain c'est
ce qu'il appelle l'épitoumia tandis que
la partie cérébrale ou la partie
intellectuelle c'est ce qu'il appelle le
nous et donc historiquement l'esprit a
toujours été valorisé par rapport au
corps parce que le travail du corps le
travail manuel c'était le travail des
esclaves c'est à dire des individus qui
n'étaient pas libres tandis que le
travail de l'esprit ce qu'on a appelé
plus tard les libérale c'était les
activités des individus détachés des
contraintes de la matière détachées des
tâches manuelles et donc on fonctionne
depuis l'Antiquité avec cette hiérarchie
corps esprit qui fait que les métiers
intellectuels donc les métiers de
l'esprit sont plus valorisés que ce soit
socialement ou économiquement et partant
de cette hiérarchie entre corps et sprit
on en est venu à considérer que ce qui
exercent des métiers physiques ou des
activités physiques bien avaient
forcément moins de capacités
intellectuelles que les autres si vous
préférez l'idée c'est que si on
travaille de son corps ça veut dire
qu'on n'est pas capable de travailler de
son esprit et ça moi c'est une
dichotomie non seulement que je refuse
que je récuse mais même que je combat
fortement parce que de mon point de vue
non seulement il n'y a pas d'opposition
entre le corps et l'esprit mais même il
y a une complémentarité nous sommes des
esprits incarnés nous sommes des esprits
qui sont véhiculés par un corps par un
corps mortel et croire que l'on pourrait
s'abstraire de l'une de ces deux
dimensions c'est pour moi avoir une
vision très réductrice de ce qu'est
l'être humain question suivante plutôt
philosophie abstraites ou terre à terre
mais là encore pour moi il y a pas
d'opposition entre les deux et
d'ailleurs c'est Eagle qui disait que
l'idée c'est ce qu'il y avait de plus
concret parce que l'idée c'est ce qui se
réalise c'est ce qui se matérialise par
l'histoire et par nos actions donc pour
ma part faire de la philosophie
déconnecté de la réalité c'est un
contresens c'est un oxymore parce que la
philosophie part toujours de
problématiques concrètes parce qu'on se
pose la question du temps ou de la mort
à cause des rides parce qu'on se pose la
question morale à partir de la trahison
et ça vous pouvez le décliner sur toutes
les problématiques matérielles
auxquelles un être humain se voit au
moins une fois confronté dans sa vie
donc je n'oppose pas la philosophie
terre à terre et la philosophie
en fait j'essaye de les unir j'essaye de
les faire se marier l'une avec l'autre
et d'ailleurs je pense que c'est ça qui
fait défaut dans l'enseignement
traditionnel de la philosophie
c'est-à-dire le fait de vouloir séparer
la philosophie de la vie concrète alors
que c'est dans la vie concrète et dans
nos vécus individuels que sans racine la
plupart de nos questionnements
philosophiques question suivante bonjour
Charles quels sont tes plus grandes
certitudes ma plus grande certitude
c'est que nos certitudes sont toujours
provisoires
quelle est la différence entre l'homme
et l'animal je dirais que la différence
entre l'homme et l'animal ce n'est pas
une différence de nature mais plutôt une
différence de degré parce que nous
sommes des animaux nous sommes
biologiquement des primates quand on
compare l'ADN de l'homme et l'ADN du
chimpanzé on s'aperçoit qu'il n'y a que
2 % de différence donc nous sommes très
proches du chimpanzé nous sommes très
proches des animaux des mammifères parce
que nous sommes des mammifères mais nous
sommes des mammifères qui sont dotés
d'une capacité particulière qu'on
appelle le langage plus exactement le
langage complexe le langage conceptuel
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes capables
d'utiliser le langage pas seulement pour
donner des indications pratiques mais
aussi pour produire de la pensée et même
si je comprends qu'on soit attaché à
l'idée de ne pas créer de hiérarchie
entre l'homme et l'animal le fait est
que l'homme possède cette faculté
particulière de pouvoir exprimer des de
pouvoir exprimer de la pensée abstraite
et que c'est cette capacité qui est au
fondement de la culture c'est à dire de
ce qui nous distingue fondamentalement
des animaux il y a des animaux
extrêmement intelligents en termes de
neurones le dauphin est deux fois plus
intelligent que l'être humain mais sauf
que le dauphin n'est pas en mesure de
traduire de convertir cette intelligence
dans des actes et dans de la culture
donc moi je dis souvent que l'homme est
un animal métaphysique c'est-à-dire
qu'il partage avec l'animal sa dimension
instinctive et pulsionnelle cette
dimension qui le rattache à l'instinct
de survie mais il en plus la capacité
symbolique c'est à dire la capacité à
créer du sens donc je veux bien qu'on ne
crée pas de hiérarchie entre l'homme et
l'animal mais force est d'admettre qu'en
terme de comparaison des facultés
l'homme en possède une que ne possède
pas la plupart des animaux question
suivante
quelle est ta définition de la liberté
pour moi la liberté c'est
l'appartenance à soi par l'attention aux
choses présentes et même si
fondamentalement je reste déterministe à
la manière de Spinoza je pense que la
notion de liberté conserve un sens parce
que la liberté c'est le fait de se dire
qu'à chaque instant on aurait pu faire
autre chose que ce qu'on a fait alors
oui le déterminisme nous dira que tout
ce qu'on a fait on était déterminé à le
faire mais se déterminisme n'enlève rien
à l'expérience du choix c'est-à-dire à
la question du dilemme j'en ai parlé
dans mon épisode sur Descartes et la
liberté le fait est que nous sommes des
êtres moraux qui ont la capacité de
regretter qui ont la capacité de penser
qu'ils ont mal agi et ça c'est quelque
chose dont son privé les animaux et
c'est quelque chose dont sont privés les
êtres mécaniques donc je dirais que la
liberté c'est cette petite parcelle de
conscience supplémentaire qui nous
permet de prendre des décision en
sachant qu'on aurait pu en prendre
d'autres
questions suivantes qu'est-ce qui est
pour toi le bonheur pour moi le bonheur
c'est quand on ne se pose plus aucune
question quand on ne s'interroge plus
sur le sens de l'existence parce que le
sens nous apparaît comme une évidence
c'est-à-dire comme quelque chose qui n'a
pas besoin d'être formulé
caisson suivantes peut-on échapper à
l'opinion alors tout dépend comment on
entend la question mais si ça veut dire
peut-on échapper à l'opinion des autres
autrement dit peut-on échapper au
jugement des autres bien ma réponse est
NON je pense qu'on est condamné à être
jugé par les autres et je pense que
c'est pas quelque chose dont il faut
forcément se plaindre ou sur quoi il
faudrait s'apitoyer la question c'est
plutôt de savoir comment on réagit au
jugement des autres et nul n'est tenu à
considérer le jugement des autres comme
une vérité absolue et ça c'est la grande
leçon des stoïciens qui est de nous dire
que on est affecté par le jugement des
autres qu'à partir du moment où on
accorde la valeur et de l'importance à
ce jugement mais où est-ce qu'on a vu
que l'opinion des autres que le jugement
des autres devait avoir un impact sur
nous le jugement des autres sur nous n'a
de valeur que celle qu'on lui accorde
mais si la question est de savoir est-ce
que l'on peut sortir de l'opinion
autrement dit est-ce que l'on n'est pas
condamné à l'opinion et bien à ce
moment-là mon avis c'est que notre
pensée est toujours un système organisé
de croyance un système organisé de
croyance autrement dit on ne peut pas
être sûr à 100% que ce que l'on pense
est une véritable absolue peut-être même
que cette notion de véritable absolue
n'a aucun sens parce que nous sommes des
êtres limités parce que nous n'avons pas
l'omniscience c'est-à-dire la capacité
de tout connaître et plutôt que de se
poser la question de savoir si ce que
l'on pense et la véritable absolue je
pense qu'on ferait mieux de se poser la
question de savoir si ce que l'on pense
correspond à notre expérience de la
réalité question suivante quelle méthode
pour dialoguer de manière constructive
avec des personnes opposées
idéologiquement ma réponse est très
simple ne pas prendre ce que l'on vous
dit personnellement quand une personne
vous exprime ses opinions
en réalité elle ne s'adresse pas à vous
vous n'êtes que le support vous n'êtes
que le réceptacle de ce qu'elle pense à
ce moment-là et si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec ce que vous dit la
personne qui est en face de vous bien
dites-vous bien que vous n'avez pas un
devoir absolu de la convaincre que vous
avez raison et qu'elle a tort ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'on a adopté
comme une sorte d'attitude mécanique le
fait d'exprimer ses désaccords mais
exprimer son désaccord ça signifie qu'on
cherche à convaincre voir à convertir
l'autre à se compense mais quel besoin
avons-nous que l'autre pense la même
chose que nous ça peut paraître bizarre
comme question parce que comme je vous
le disais on a tous cette habitude
mécanique de vouloir faire comprendre à
l'autre ce que l'on pense et pourquoi ce
que l'on pense serait vrai mais la
personne elle pense qu'elle pense elle a
ses convictions elle a suivi son propre
chemin d'évolution et de toute façon
vous ne pourrez pas la convaincre que
vous avez raison parce que ce qui fait
que vous pensez avoir raison c'est le
fait d'avoir suivi votre propre chemin
d'évolution donc oui vous pouvez
dialoguer avec la personne vous pouvez
échanger des idées mais le fait de
vouloir convaincre l'autre que vous avez
raison ça me semble être un projet perdu
d'avance on crée beaucoup plus de remise
en cause on crée beaucoup plus de remise
en question simplement en écoutant
l'autre et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
sous-estime énormément le pouvoir de
l'écoute parce que l'écoute est un moyen
de recevoir et de recueillir les paroles
de l'autre tout en créant les conditions
de leur remise en cause question
suivante tu crois vraiment à la
puissance de la philosophie pour
gouverner la vie d'un individu vivant à
notre époque oui je crois à la puissance
de la philosophie comme capacité de
s'auto-gouverner c'est à dire comme
capacité de ne pas recevoir ses opinions
d'une autorité extérieure question
suivante
peut-on dire que la société n'a jamais
été aussi superficielle qu'actuellement
oui on peut le dire mais je pense qu'on
pourra également le dire dans 20 ans
dans 50 ans ou dans 100 ans ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'à chaque fois
que je lis ou que j'entends ce genre de
question je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'y
voir une posture moralisatrice une
posture de jugement qui consiste à
distribuer les bons et les mauvais
points qu'est-ce que la superficialité à
partir de quand on est superficiel
est-ce que montrer ces photos de
vacances c'est la superficialité est-ce
qu'avoir un compte Facebook ou un compte
Instagram c'est la superficialité est-ce
que ce coiffer se maquiller prendre une
douche tous les matins c'est la
superficialité c'est bien beau de
vouloir dénoncer la superficialité des
autres mais ce qu'on met autant
d'entrains est-ce qu'on met autant
d'énergie dans la dénonciation de sa
propre superficialité moi je veux bien
qu'on dénonce la superficialité mais
j'écouterai quelqu'un dénoncé la
superficialité quand il dénoncera sa
superficialité parce que c'est facile de
dire que les autres sont superficielles
mais est-ce que ce n'est pas superficiel
de les juger sur leur apparence est-ce
que ce n'est pas superficiel de se faire
une image de quelqu'un à partir d'une
photo qu'il poste sur Instagram et pour
moi dès lors qu'on est dans la recherche
de ce qui ne va pas chez l'autre
lorsqu'on est dans le pointage des
défauts et dans cette attitude un petit
peu professoral et moralisatrice qui
consiste à désigner ce qui ne va pas on
est dans la superficialité alors bien
sûr je ne m'en prends pas à toi qui pose
cette question je saisis l'occasion que
tu me donnes de pouvoir faire cette mise
au point parce que je pense que cette
mentalité qui consiste à pointer
systématiquement ce qui ne va pas et
fondamentalement contradictoire avec ce
que je cherche à proposer à travers mon
travail c'est à dire des outils
d'émancipation des outils d'amélioration
et non pas des outils de dénonciation ou
de jugement qui ne font finalement que
nous maintenir dans la négativité
question suivante
penses-tu que la plupart des philosophes
étaient misogynes oui en fait c'est pas
que la plupart des philosophes étaient
misogynes c'est que tout ce qui
appartient au passé est aujourd'hui
considéré comme misogyne parce que ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la misogynie
ou la xénophobie ou la pensée
réactionnaire c'est d'abord le produit
d'une différence générationnelle et
d'une différence culturelle c'est très
facile de juger le passé en se disant
que ceux qui ont vécu avant nous
n'étaient pas conscients ne comprenait
pas certaines choses parce que dans 20
ans dans 30 ans ou dans 100 ans c'est
nous qui serons jugés réactionnaires par
la postérité ce que je veux dire c'est
que ceux qui se targuent d'être les plus
progressistes aujourd'hui seront jugés
comme d'infâmes réactionnaires par les
plus progressistes de la génération
suivante en histoire il y a une erreur
de débutant qu'on nous apprend à ne pas
commettre qui s'appelle l'anachronisme
l'anachronisme c'est ce qui consiste à
jeter Aristote à la poubelle parce qu'a
Aristote était pour l'esclavage c'est ce
qui consiste à jeter Jean-Jacques
Rousseau à la poubelle parce que
Rousseau a tenu des propos homophobes et
c'est ce qui consiste aujourd'hui à
jeter Simone Veil à la poubelle Simone
Veil qui a été l'une des plus grandes
protagonistes de la légalisation de
l'avortement sous prétexte qu'elle
critique la théorie du genre donc à une
époque où on envisage l'intégralité des
rapports sociaux sous l'angle exclusif
de la discrimination ou de la
stigmatisation il est évident que tout
ce qui appartient au passé peut être
jugé misogyne et actionnaire question
suivante
as-tu un roman qui est à profondément
marqué et que tu recommandes oui je l'ai
déjà dit à de nombreuses reprises le
roman que je recommande pour s'initier à
la littérature philosophique c'est
l'étranger d'Albert Camus parce que
c'est un roman qui est derrière une
apparente simplicité d'écriture
dissimulant fait une grande profondeur
philosophique et parce que c'est un
roman qui permet de comprendre en quoi
il ne fait pas bon être inadapté aux
normes sociales question suivante
pourquoi Meursault passe pour insolent
aux yeux des autres voir l'étranger
vient justement Meursault passe pour
insolent parce qu'il n'épouse pas le
modèle social majoritaire qui est le
modèle social de la politesse la
politesse étymologiquement ça vient du
mot police qui signifie la cité et donc
la politesse c'est le fait de vivre en
bonne harmonie avec ses semblables sauf
que comme le disait Rousseau la
politesse comporte nécessairement une
part d'hypocrisie c'est-à-dire que quand
on est poli on referme
une part de notre agressivité naturelle
et c'est Freud qui disaient que pour
vivre en société nous étions obligés
d'en rabattre sur notre pulsion et ça
c'est le rôle du surmoi dans rabattre
sur notre pulsion pour que la société ne
devienne pas un chaos permanent pour
qu'elle ne devienne pas ce que Obs
s'appelait la guerre de tous contre tous
et bien Meursault c'est celui qui décide
de ne pas céder à cet injonction à la
politesse qui décide de rester lui-même
c'est-à-dire de s'exprimer sans filtre
et ce qui est intéressant chez Meursault
c'est qu'il ne le fait pas dans le but
de faire du mal aux autres il se
contente d'être lui-même il se contente
d'être indifférent aux affects sociaux
qu'on l'oblige à éprouver et c'est pour
ça qu'il sera condamné il sera condamné
parce qu'il n'a pas versé une larme à
l'enterrement de sa mère donc je vous
invite fortement à lire ce petit roman
d'Albert Camus qui constitue selon moi
l'une des meilleures introductions
littéraires à la philosophie question
suivante
faut-il absolument souffrir pour évoluer
je réponds que oui parce que
étymologiquement souffrir c'est subir et
ce qui nous fait évoluer dans la vie
c'est ce que l'on subit c'est ce que
l'on choisit pas c'est à dire c'est ce à
quoi on ne s'attend pas nous évoluons
parce que nous possédons une capacité
d'adaptation et ce qui caractérise les
êtres vivants et en particulier l'être
humain c'est sa capacité d'adaptation or
quand une situation nous fait perdre
tous nos moyens lorsqu'on ne comprend
pas ce qui nous arrive on n'a pas
d'autre choix que de s'y adapter c'est à
dire d'évoluer si on ne souffre pas on
n'a aucune raison d'évoluer parce qu'on
a aucune raison de vouloir éviter de
souffrir à nouveau et ça c'est ce qui
arrive le plus souvent lorsqu'on souffre
lorsqu'on échoue ou lorsqu'on est déçu
parce que si on ne souffrait pas on
aurait aucune raison de se remettre en
cause alors bien sûr quand on souffre on
vit ça comme une expérience purement
négatives parce qu'à ce moment là on
n'est pas conscient de l'amélioration et
de l'évolution dont cette souffrance est
porteuse mais pour peu qu'on tienne le
coup et qu'on surpasse cette souffrance
on va s'apercevoir qu'on en est ressorti
grandit qu'on en est ressorti un peu
plus sage un peu plus conscient la vie
est faite d'imprévus de choses dont on
ne pouvait pas se douter qu'elles
allaient arriver et c'est ça qui nous
fait grandir et je ne crois pas du tout
dans la capacité à apprendre par
procuration c'est à dire à évoluer grâce
aux témoignage des autres ou aux
enseignements délivrés par les autres je
pense que les témoignages sont comme des
marques pages dans le livre de notre
existence et qu'ils ont pour rôle de
nous rappeler lorsque nous vivons
nous-mêmes l'expérience
quel est l'enseignement que nous allons
en tirer il faut écouter les conseils
des autres et les témoignages des autres
non pas parce qu'ils vont modifier notre
comportement et notre vision du monde
mais parce que le jour venu lorsque nous
vivrons cette expérience nous nous
rappellerons de ces témoignages et nous
saurons quelle leçon il faut en tirer
question suivante penses-tu que la
société fait tout pour anéantir la
population mondiale et nous rendre
stupides je pense que la société fait
tout pour nous anéantir
intellectuellement pour nous anéantir
spirituellement
et pour anéantir notre esprit critique
et enfin dernière question
peut-on légitimement vouloir améliorer
le monde sans s'améliorer soi-même non
je pense que vouloir améliorer le monde
c'est souvent un prétexte bien pratique
pour détourner le regard de ce que l'on
devrait améliorer en soi que c'est
facile de pointer du doigt ce qui ne va
pas à l'extérieur de soi mais
j'accorderai de la légitimité à ceux qui
veulent améliorer le monde
lorsqu'ils commenceront par dire que ce
qui ne va pas dans le monde
c'est d'abord eux-mêmes vouloir
améliorer le monde c'est une manière de
vouloir combattre à l'extérieur de soi
une bataille qui se livre d'abord à
l'intérieur de soi et qu'on est très
fort pour repérer ce qui ne va pas dans
le monde sans se rendre compte que ce
qui ne va pas dans le monde
et souvent le reflet de ce qui ne va pas
chez nous je crois beaucoup à cette idée
du transfert de la projection qui fait
qu'on va d'autant plus dénoncer ce qui
nous scandalise ce qui nous dérange ce
qui nous meurtrit chez les autres sans
se rendre compte que ce qui nous dérange
se trouve d'abord en nous et
entendons-nous bien je ne suis pas du
tout en train de critiquer la volonté
d'améliorer le monde je suis en train de
critiquer la stratégie qui consiste à
déporter la faute sur les autres plutôt
que sur soi-même si vous voulez
sincèrement
et authentiquement améliorer le monde
ne dites pas au monde ce qu'il doit être
soyez ce que vous voulez que le monde
soit
[Musique]